if you told me 15 years ago that I
needed to talk about it I would have
laughed you out of the room you're so
lucky if you're a party every day it
becomes boring especially if it's a
party
I've seen it a lot well I don't believe
you Gary I'm like because you don't know
me oh my boss is quit well I can't I
have bills to pay Gary it's poking and
so people don't want it it's fine yet
it's life changing
when you were coming to the Expo in
Sharjah yes I remember
I went back because I know I'm a
guardian people
just enjoy life
depression and I told you that I'll see
you in three years it's been probably
five now good for you I'm so happy too
I'm proud of you it's amazing yeah good
for you and um I love that content so I
never get an answer
of your company which is what I think
battling through which both are amazing
yeah I think it's a game of what are you
built for self-awareness yeah it's all
self-awareness accountability
huge it was a change of my life when I
saw comfort about accountability 100 so
wonderful to hear you say that I am
fascinated by how people respond to when
I talk about accountability it's poking
and so people don't want it yet it's
everything it will do so much for people
it's life-changing and right now the
world is going the other way it's
telling you what every single thing is
bad and everything social media
traditional media politics Society is
pushing everyone to see the thing they
should blame for their unhappiness and
the second you go to accountability all
your happiness starts to build money
that's a little bit longer sometimes of
course you know I'll shut everybody out
yeah but the problem is I'd Rather Be
Lonely with myself and accountability
than to have people around me that are
pushing non-accountability having
Circles of energy that are pushing
non-accountability all those friends the
media your feed your friends who are
pushing blame and envy and jealousy I'd
rather be by myself in accountability
yes
yeah to me it's like as I go through my
journey you know you go around the world
you have conversations I'm always paying
attention I spend my time listening and
then I'm able to talk that's why I like
q a that's why I like reading my
messages because it enables me to know
what to talk about if you told me 15
years ago that I needed to talk about
accountability I would have laughed you
out of the room I would say why everyone
knows that's real I could have never
anticipated the world being so effective
of eliminating accountability
when I'm all wrapped up I'll make that
decision but what's cool is I'm really
have a genuinely enjoyed every different
chapter I do think the V friends thing
has very substantial potential for me
because I really love storytelling it's
why garyvee has done well but this is a
whole universe so I'm genuinely excited
about that
I think the future of marketing is the
history of marketing which is wherever
the consumer's attention is whoever
understands where it is fastest and best
and knows how to fill that attention
with stories in video written or picture
form will have the most upset right
I mean all that I'm doing right now with
social media is what the Pioneers of
Television did in the 1950s and 60s
that's all it is the concept of debating
would you rather be by yourself and your
accountability versus being around
humans or energy that are looking for
eliminating accountability and you know
friends that come with energy that is in
the blame game versus yourself and you
and your accountability that's different
than saying friends who are also
reinforcing positivity and
accountability is even better than you
by yourself but friends who are pushing
Envy blame and jealousy that's what's
happening we are in scaled blame Envy
jealousy the Jeb we've got to eliminate
the Jeb the jealousy envy and blame
you know where people struggle something
can be true but not have to destroy you
it can be true that you're being
suppressed it can be true that your
bosses you it could be true that your
government it could be true that your
boss is trying to undermine you but it
doesn't mean that it should ruin you
there isn't a human that's ever walked
this Earth that hasn't had negative
energy against them the question becomes
what do you do with it I mean look at
the energy of the UAE you can move here
you could that's the accountability
thing like oh my boss is me quit well I
can't I have bills to pay Gary get a
different job so instead of coming home
and like venting for six hours you could
be on LinkedIn for three hours that
would set up your job but a lot of
people would rather go and get on Xbox
or like call their mom or go to the bar
and drink their worries away or keep
their worries away or watch sports to
distract them or whatever it is it's
easier my dad was in such a I wouldn't
have no self-esteem to quit my job cool
but like what are you gonna do that
until you die but I think that's also
fine it's fine look I'm all about a pity
party we all have to have them even I
have pity parties in my own head once
every decade but if you're a party every
day it becomes boring especially if it's
a pity party my big thing on this is
this comes from a deep place of
compassion and empathy and sympathy this
is not coming from a place of crudeness
or no care I just have not seen it ever
work out in the concept of scale
dwelling I've just never seen it work
out it's not like you just dwell your
way to happiness you can't throw a pity
party all the way in and miraculously
the 80th day you're like now I'm fixed
you're just digging a deeper grave on
the flip side I've seen people
completely and utterly transform with
accountability like
like 37 years seeing the world one way
one year of pounding yourself with
accountability and waking up and just
seen it a lot 7 20 30 40 Good Times
which is amazing gives me enormous
passion to keep doing it and it's also
that people don't know that they are
doing it correct by the way every human
being is doing things that they can't
see in themselves I like to pride myself
in being incredibly self-aware I think
about it every day it is the pillar that
I speak on and I've done many things in
the last decade where I wake up and I'm
like wait a minute I didn't realize I
wasn't being cameras for two decades and
that it was causing me shortcomings and
vulnerabilities I thought I was doing a
good thing but I was not hurting
people's feelings and thought I was
putting a lot of effort to making it
good I thought I was doing good I'm not
going to hurt their feelings but we're
still going to get to a good outcome my
own expense but it's not as good you
know for me to go through that that was
a hard Revelation and so yes I
understand your parents were alcoholics
yes I understand that there's sexism and
racism and religious persecution I
understand all of that to be true you
can do something people in North Korea
can't do anything they can escape North
Korea they can even do something people
try to escape the Soviet Union people
take little tiny boats from Cuba people
try to cross the border into South Korea
people risk their life to change their
outcome
they feel like you're not aware of the
actual circumstances here but when you
say that they get include it and they
feel like oh okay he's aware this is
great yeah and I also never try to
convince people that I'm aware or I'm
never hurt by people not realizing how
much I think about it because that's
their reality you know I think the thing
that people struggle with is they try to
convince I think what's making
everything work for me and be
sustainable is I'm not trying to
convince I'm really not even like an
interview some for like your advice like
I don't even think of it as advice I
genuinely know I think I'm just
communicating and hoping it's like a
hope that it may trigger a different
perspective shift the other thing that's
tough right now is back to pointing
fingers versus accountability is people
projecting things about people they
don't know they're like you have it so
good because you're rich like oh you're
so lucky well I don't believe you Gary
I'm like because you don't know me you
can't believe I get that you know hard
work is part of the equation you could
be born outrageously beautiful if you
don't go to the gym and if you don't
have discipline and what you consume
you're not going to be able to be a
model that makes money on brand deals
like it's just real life the person
doesn't exist that hasn't put hard work
into the equation it doesn't exist
that's something the world has to wrap
its head around otherwise it's woe is me
I was born with this I got unlucky it's
unbelievable how big dwelling has become
cultural it was like unheard of in the
90s it's also hard to document the
mundane and even when you do people
don't believe it I've documented my full
days and people are like this isn't true
in the comments this is fake how how's
it fake I think there needs to be more
responsibility on the consumer of her
not the producer of I do think there's a
huge responsibility to produce her up
that's why I don't show a lot of things
but again I actually on this subcenter
think it's another version of blame why
don't we just all assume that everyone
did put in work I do huge game of
accountability but when I see anybody
I'm like they worked I think people are
asking for something that they're not
deploying they want that person that
influence or whatever to deploy empathy
for them yet they're not deploying
empathy or compassion to that person
right show me your vulnerability cool
makes sense but to me why decide someone
is perfect when I literally look around
the room my brain goes into thinking
about how many different things may be a
struggle for them compassion it's a very
opposite view it's so weird
foreign